okay girls I'm gonna say whatever I
think so all the girls out there who
actually like wanted to be perfect
perfect doesn't exist you don't have to
become Britney Spears or Beyonce in
order to be happy
confidence is not something that happens
overnight don't rush yourself every room
you enter you belong you're not supposed
to not be somewhere you're not the
person who doesn't belong you're not the
person who should be sitting in the back
of the room if you're in that room
you're supposed to be in that room
you're probably the smartest person in
that room and act like it as long as
you're doing one thing one thing a day
to make yourself feel empowered or feel
loved or just look at yourself in the
mirror go dang girl you look good today
loving yourself as a process and
everybody's on their own clock be free
be wild stay creative write song you
talk about yourself you need to like let
it out you are responsible for your own
happiness and you need to go and find it
even your most depressing days are part
of your evolution that life is just
about believing yourself believing in
your dreams and you are the dream so as
long as you're believing yourself you
are completing everything that is
necessary for you here in this time in
this lifetime in this moment what you
have to offer is everything that we mean
believe that there's so much power in
each other it's important to know that
you have a community of girls and women
supporting you I am one of those people
we are here for you find happiness and
little things and they will get bigger
and bigger and bigger at the end of the
day
you are striving for perfection you're
never going to get what you want what
you need to strive for is being your
true authentic self and that is when
you're going to really find peace you're
gonna find success and you're gonna find
love and the best way possible
I think the most important thing is to
just be you cuz nobody else is my
parents were amazing and they told me as
long as I could dream it I could be it I
truly believe that and so that means to
this day I'm pretty sure I could still
win an Olympic gold medal in figure
skating even though I'm Way too rich so
but if I could dream it I can be it
right